the White House is also taking aim at
the cdc's newest guidance on the Corona
virus as our lead National correspondent
David begno reports its director warns
that a vast majority of people in this
country remain at
risk most Americans have not been
infected with the virus and are still
vulnerable to the infection that is the
CDC director Dr Robert Redfield he urged
Americans on Wednesday not to let their
guard down announcing that preliminary
findings from a new nation wide antibod
study shows that about 90% of Americans
are still susceptible to the virus yeah
I think that Dr Redfield uh misstated
something there that is the newest
member of the White House Corona virus
task force Dr Scott Atlas he challenged
Dr redfield's report saying he was
partially relying on old data CBS News
medical correspondent Dr John leuk it's
a basic rule of Public Health that you
have to have one message no mixed
messages and you want to hear that from
people who spent their career figuring
out how do you explain complex health
issues to the public and then there was
this moment on Capitol Hill yesterday Dr
Anthony fouchy clashed with Senator Rand
Paul over Public Health orders and what
role they've played in keeping the virus
at Bay in New York City they are looking
at the guidelines that we have put
together from the task force or they've
developed enough Community immunity that
they're no longer having the pandemic
because they have enough immunity in New
York City to actually stop I challenge
that uh Senator because I want please
sir I would like to be able to do this
because this happens with Senator Rand
all the time you were not listening to
what the director of the CDC said that
in New York it's about 22% if you
believe 22% is HT immunity I believe
you're alone in
that not only is Dr fouchy right but New
York City is getting it right the test
positivity rate here in the city and
even Statewide is roughly 1% but the
city's not taking any chances as our
businesses in fact the fame New York
opera The Metropolitan Opera behind me
they announced yesterday they will not
reopen until September of next year it
is the first time Gail they've skipped
an entire season in 140 years yeah a lot
of people making big changes but very
interesting exchange between Rand Paul
and Dr fouchy both sides feel very
strongly in their positions thank you
David